>> DELICIOUS.
DELICIOUS.
HAPPY FRIDAY, MY FRIDAY FRIENDS.
CHINA'S PRESIDENT IS MATT, AND
NOT BECAUSE LeBRON JAMES IS A
LOUSY KISSER.
BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI, THIS PORK
WITH EYEBROWS TOOK A GIRLS
SHOPPING TRIP TO TAIWAN.
CHINA'S SENT SCORES OF PLANES T
THE TAIWAN STRAIT AND FIRED LIV
MISSILES NEAR THE ISLAND.
TO BE FAIR THEY WEREN'T HER
COMMITTEE SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T
HEAR THEM BECAUSE SHE FORGOT TO
CHARGE THE BATTERIES IN HER
MIRACLE EAR.
U.S. MILITARY BRASS RESPONDED
IMMEDIATELY MOBILIZING TROOPS
FOR AN EMERGENCY PRONOUNS
WORKSHOP.
SO CHINA FIRED A LOAD OF
MISSILES, ACTIVATED 100 PLANES
INCLUDING FIGHTER JETS AND
BOMBERS AND TEN WARSHIPS, DON'T
THEY KNOW HOW BAD ALL OF THAT I
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT?
HOW IS THE MEDIA HANDLING THIS?
IMAGINE A COUNTRY THIS IS A
WARNING TELLING YOU WHAT YOU'RE
ABOUT TO DO CROSSES THE LINE AN
YET YOU DO IT ANYWAY.
IT'S LIKE WHEN MY WIFE TELLS ME
TO STOP LEAVING MY SHOES AND
FLOCKS ON THE FLOOR AND THE
RECUT THOSE FULL HOUSE.
CHINA SAYS DON'T GO TO TAIWAN,
BUT SCREW YOU CHINA, WE ARE
COMING OVER.
WHICH ARE THE SECRET SERVICE
NICKNAMES FOR BIDEN AND HARRIS.
SO LIKE A DIVORCE LAWYER, YOU
DRIVE UP TENSIONS BETWEEN
ADVERSARIES WHILE DRIVING ONE
ENEMY INTO THE ARMS OF ANOTHER,
OR SHIPS, PLANES, MISSILES, ALL
THAT'S MISSING IS THIS.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY NANCY PELOSI
DOING WINDOWSHOPPING.
TAIWAN THREATENED BY BATTLESHIP
AND BATTLE AXES.
AFTER WONDER WHAT NANCY'S
HUSBAND IS DOING RIGHT NOW.
BUT, THE REVENGE HAS ONLY JUST
BEGUN.
THIS IS ONE EXPENSIVE SHOPPING
TRIP FROM THE GET-GO.
IT ALREADY COST THE TAXPAYERS
MILLIONS INCLUDING THE TAXPAYER
IN PELOSI'S DISGUSTING DISTRICT
HIM FRANCISCO WHICH AS YOU KNOW
LOOKS LIKE THIS.
SHE'S GOT HER PRIORITIES
STRAIGHT FOR THE FACT IS SHE
DIDN'T NEED TO FLY, HER EYEBROW
ARE ALREADY IN THE MILE HIGH
CLUB.
IT LOOKS LIKE SOMEBODY JUST
SHOWED HER MY READINGS.
SO SHE GOES OUT OF HER WAY TO
TAKE CHINA OFF AFTER TELLING
EVERYBODY ELSE NOT TO DO HER TH
VERY SAME THING.
I WOULD TELL HER TO FACE, BUT
THAT IS FIVE PACES AGO.
WHAT KIND OF LEADER WOULD DO
SOMETHING SO STUPID ASIDE FROM
THE CURRENT PRESENT WHO NEEDS
TRAINING WHEELS FOR HIS BIKE.
WE WERE ALWAYS TOLD THAT IT
WOULD BE THIS GUY THAT WOULD
CAUSE UNREST ROETHKE GET THE
RECKLESS REST DECISIONS ARE NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR REAL GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP.
>> MULTIPLE CRISES EXACERBATED
BY THE ERRATIC AND UNTETHERED
FOREIGN POLICY.
>> WHAT YOU NEED TO DO IS LOWER
THE TEMPERATURE AND NOT INCREAS
THE TEMPERATURE, AND IN A WAY I
THINK YOU COULD SAY HE'S PLAYIN
RIGHT INTO KIM'S HANDS.
>> SO IT'S THE NATURE OF THIS
WHICH I DON'T THINK IS STRATEGI
WHICH LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THAT
TRUMP IS IN SERIOUS AND MAY NOT
BE UP TO THE JOB.
>> A MAN YOU CAN FACE WITH A
TWEET IS NOT A MAN WE CAN TRUST
WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS PRICKED.
>> SHE LOOKED SO MUCH HEALTHIER
BEFORE SHE KILLED JEFFREY
EPSTEIN.
BUT SERIOUSLY, WHERE IS JOE WHE
IT COMES TO CHINA?
WHAT THE HELL, JOE?
>> I CAN'T TELL THAT LADY WHAT
TO DO.
I DIDN'T WANT HER TO GO, BUT DI
YOU EVER TRIED TO TELL AN OLD
LADY WHAT TO DO?
I SAY GO AHEAD, GO TO CHINA, I
DON'T CARE.
I'M A LITTLE AFRAID OF HER
ANYWAY.
I'M MORE AFRAID OF NANCY THEN
THE CHINESE.
DID YOU SEE WHEN SHE RIPPED UP
THAT STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS?
I SAID THAT IS ONE DIZZY BROAD,
STAY OUT OF HER WAY.
I PROBABLY CAN'T SAY THAT, THEY
WILL PUT ME BACK IN THE BASEMENT
.
SO TRUMP WAS THE DANGER.
SIDE DON'T THINK SO.
LIKE PELOSI HE DIDN'T GO TO AN
ADVERSARY AND STICK AT THEM IN
THEIR EYE, HE WENT THERE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WE WANT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE ARE IN CLOSE CONTACT.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY AT LEAS
RHETORICALLY WITH NORTH KOREA.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT THING FOR
THE WORLD.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT ALL COMES
ABOUT.
>> WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
FOR GOING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> SO USING BASIC SALES
TECHNIQUES TRUMP REMOVED THE
NUMBER ONE THREAT OFF THE TABLE
ACCORDING TO OBAMA AND HE DID I
WITHOUT RISKING WHAT TROOPS LIVE
.
WE SEE THE CHAOS THAT'S HAPPENE
SINCE, CHINA, MOBILIZING AGAINS
TAIWAN, RUSSIA INVADING UKRAINE
WILL SMITH MAKING THE OSCARS
WATCHABLE.
HOW ABOUT THE MIDDLE EAST?
IT ANYBODY ELSE DID THE ABRAHAM
ACCORDS, THEY WOULD RECEIVE THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
OR AT LEAST A HAPPY ENDING FROM
JERRY NADLER.
THE FACT IS TRUMP HAS BEEN THE
MOST ANTIWAR PRESIDENT IN RECEN
HISTORY UNDER HIM FEWER PEOPLE
DIED WHILE TERRORISTS WERE
LOOKING OVER THEIR SHOULDERS
LIKE OUR KELLY IN THE PRISON
SHOWERS.
MEANWHILE, IT'S THE DEMS THAT
ARE THE DOPES CREATING GLOBAL
INSTABILITY.
CREEDAL HOW THE MEDIA MIGHT
HANDLE THIS PROVOCATION IF TRUM
HAD DONE IT.
BUT YOU WILL NEVER KNOW BECAUSE
TRUMP NEVER WOULD HAVE DONE THAT
.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE COST OF THING
HE UNDERSTOOD LEVERAGE, WHICH
PELOSI JUST HANDED TO THE
CHINESE.
THE FACT IS WE FORGET WHAT TRUM
WAS ACCUSED OF DOING BECAUSE TH
ACTUAL DOING NEVER HAPPENED.
AND THE ACCUSERS ARE FULFILLING
THE VERY THINGS THEY ACCUSED HI
OF DOING.
UNDER TRUMP, NO WAR IS JUST
PEACEFUL ACCORDS AND HANDSHAKES
RIGHT UNDER BIDEN, HOT WORDS,
COLD WARS, STORAGE WARS.
BUT YOU KNOW THANK GOD WE GOT
RID OF THOSE TWEETS.
NOW WE CAN ALL SLEEP THE SLEEP
OF ANGELS KNOWING HIS TWEETS AR
NO LONGER OUT THERE WANDERING
THE COSMOS LOOKING TO HURT
SOMEBODY'S FEELINGS ANYMORE.
LIKE THIS ONE.
EVERY TIME I SPEAK OF THE HATER
AND LOSERS, I DO SO WITH GREAT
LOVE AND AFFECTION.
THEY CANNOT HELP THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE BORN [BLEEP]".
THEY STILL HIT.
I'M ASSUMING THAT ISRAEL.
OUT ABOUT THIS ONE.
SORRY LOSERS AND HATERS, BUT MY
IQ IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST AND YO
ALL KNOW IT VERY DON'T FEEL SO
STUPID OR INSECURE, IT'S NOT
YOUR FAULT.
AND PERHAPS THE ONE THAT STARTE
IT ALL, WHEN SOME GUY TWEETS AT
TRUMP, IF YOU HATE AMERICA SO
MUCH YOU SHOULD RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AND FIX THINGS.
TRUMP TWEETS BACK BE CAREFUL
BIRD THAT WAS A BIGGER THREAT
THAN ANYTHING WE EVER KNEW SO W
KICKED HIM OUT AND REPLACED THE
WITH AN IDIOT FOR A GUY THAT
DOESN'T KNOW HE'S DOING THESE
BAD THINGS UNTIL HE WATCHES THE
LOCAL NEWS.
WE HAVE NANCY TO THINK FOR THE
LATEST CHAOS FOR ITS IT'S
AMAZING SHE CAN DO HER JOB WITH
A STRAIGHT FACE.
NOT REALLY.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
WHEN SHE TALKS BEN SHAPIRO ASKE
HER TO SLOW DOWN.
EMILY COMPAGNO.
HE IS ONE OF OUR FAVORITE FACES
AND GETS ALL THE BEST PARKING
SPACES.
HE IS THE ONLY DOG WHO HAS YOU
WAIT WHILE HE GETS UNDRESSED.
DR. DREW.
NOT TRUE BY THE WAY.
THE ONLY THING THAT SHE SMOKES
IS HER COMPETITION.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
EMILY, HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M GOOD.
SO JOEY.
THAT WAS A JOKE.
IT'S FRIDAY.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THE TRIP VERY
DID ANYTHING POSITIVE COME OUT
OF THIS TRIP?
TAKE IT NOT THAT I KNOW OF SO
FAR.
YOU NAILED IT WHEN YOU SAID THA
TRUMP UNDERSTOOD AND HERE WE
HAVE THE SPEAKER THEY SAID THE
PURPOSE AT THAT VISIT WAS TO NO
DISRUPT THE STATUS QUO.
IN FACTORIES OR FOR.
WE WILL NOT STAND BY AND LET
CHINA ISOLATE TAIWAN.
SINCE SHE'S BEEN IN THE 52ND
SINCE CHINA HAS UNLEASHED HELL
ON TAIWAN DRONES, MILITARY
DRONES AND ICBMS, THE FIRST IN
HISTORY THAT WENT OVER THEIR
LAND INTERRUPTING THEIR
$320 BILLION TOURNAMENT IN THE
FIRST TABLE AND THEY STOPPED 10
SHIPS FROM LEAVING TAIWAN.
CYBER ATTACKS, DRONES, AND THEN
THE U.S. AMBASSADOR TO CHINA
SAID WE ARE GOING TO MAKE YOU
PAY THE PRICE.
SIMILAR TO WHEN A HUMAN AND
HAMPTON ANIMAL OR A BUTTERFLY,
AND THEN THEY CRUSH IT
ACCIDENTALLY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE.
I THINK HER ARROGANCE IN HER
MAINTAINING WE ARE HERE TO
PRESERVE EVERYTHING.
SHE IS WALKING WITH A FIXED
EXPRESSION.
INTO YOUR POINT, FOLLOW.
>> WHAT IS WORSE, CALLING IT TH
CHINA VIRUS OR INCITING WORLD
WAR III WITH A SHOPPING TRIP TO
TAIWAN?
I THINK THAT IS A LOADED
QUESTION.
>> IF YOU'RE A LIBERAL, I MEAN
CALLING COVID THE CHINA VIRUS
WAS REALLY BAD.
I THINK ONE OF THE FUNNIEST
THINGS ABOUT THIS IS NANCY
PELOSI WITH SANCTIONS.
COULDN'T SANCTION ME.
IT HAVE TO HACK INTO MY AMAZON
ACCOUNT.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
SANCTIONING NANCY PELOSI.
SHE IS.
>> I AM NOT SAYING SHE'S DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
>> THEY ALSO SANCTIONED HER
HUSBAND.
THEY SANCTION FAMILY MEMBERS TO
WHICH MEANS HE GOT IN GOOD AND
TROUBLED THAN HE DID IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> WHAT YOU MAKE OF ALL OF THIS?
IT'S LIKE THE REVERSE PROJECTION
.
ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN UNDER TRUMP.
>> THAT SEEMS TO BE THE PRIMARY
PSYCHOLOGICAL PROCESS THAT GOES
ON WHICH IS PEOPLE HAVE THEIR
OWN INTERNAL SORT OF FEELINGS
THAT THEY DISAVOW AND THEY
PROJECT THEM ONTO EVERYBODY ELSE
.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE
SEEING HERE.
MY WIFE TURNED ME TODAY AND SAI
WHY DIDN'T WHAT'S HIS NAME GO.
I SAID THE PRESIDENT FAX AND
THEN SHE GOES IS HE DEAD?
WAS LIKE WHY, WOW, WE ARE THERE.
>> HE DID HAVE THAT WEEKEND AND
BERNIE'S LOOK TODAY WITH THE
GLASSES ON.
>> DO YOU THINK THERE IS AN ALL
TERRIER MOTIVE WITH LAKE.
ITS GREAT WAY TO GO OUT.
WHAT WAS SHE THINKING.
WHAT WAS SHE TRYING TO GET OUT
OF IT.
MAY BE DISTRACTING THE HUSBAND.
THAT IS THE THING ABOUT THIS IS
CHIC IN THE LIVER CRITICIZE
REPUBLICANS OF BEING ANTI-
CLIMATE BECAUSE NOT ONLY WAS TH
FLIGHT OBVIOUSLY, BUT NOW CHINA
PULLS OUT OF EVERY CLIMATE
AGREEMENT AND EVERYTHING.
>> WHY ARE THEY FREAKED OUT
ABOUT THAT.
CHINA SAYS WE DON'T HAVE TO DO
THAT ANYMORE.
>> WHY IS INTER CAN CONSTITUENC
APOPLECTIC ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF
THE PROBLEM.
FOR GATE THEIR CONSISTENCY IS T
HAVE RICH PEOPLE ACT HOMELESS.
I WAS GOING TO SAY SOMETHING
DISGUSTING CAT, BUT THAT WOULD
BE SO UNLIKE YOU.
IS THERE ANYTHING GOOD FOR THIS?
FOR HER FOR A LITTLE BIT, FOR
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES SHE HAD
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE SAYING, WAY TO GO.
FOR A LITTLE BIT, SHE WAS NOT I
THE HEADLINES FOR HER HUSBAND
AND HIS JOYRIDE GONE AWRY.
BUT THAT'S THE ONLY THING IT DID
.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY IS
AWFUL.
I GET THAT INVASION TO TAIWAN
WOULD BE TERRIBLE WHAT SHE DID
MAKE THAT MORE LIKELY NOT LESS
LIKELY.
SHE HAD ALL THESE PEOPLE TELL
HER.
AND LEAVE AND BE OUT OF THERE.
>> EXACTLY.
IT IS CRAZY.
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT
REPUBLICANS.
EXCEPT FOR TWO, WHICH WAS REALL
INTERESTING.
THE TWO PEOPLE WHO HATE EACH
OTHER BOTH SAID THIS WAS A BAD
IDEA.
WHEN YOU HAVE TWO PEOPLE THAT
HATE EACH OTHER.
>> BECAUSE PEOPLE ARGUE FOR
THINGS LIKE THIS.